good afternoon and welcome to the
session on the electronic deposit of
dissertations I'm Carlos alone so the
current Dean of the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences and I was asked to
preface the proceedings and I gladly
agreed to do so because this is a
project that is very dear to my heart
and one that I think is a harbinger of
many many other such opportunities in
the future the contemporary American
University has been built on two
contradictory conceits on the one hand
the university is a p is a place
rhetorically and conceptually outside
society where pragmatism and
instrumentality are not invoked as
criteria of valorisation this is why
universities typically have been built
away from the city in isolation from the
urban and it's hustle and bustle you
just have to remember Colombia's history
moving upward in Manhattan to flee the
city which is by the way a very also a
very American understanding of the
University in Europe universities tend
to be anchored very clearly in the in
the urban mostly because of a historical
difference in the in the foundations of
universities of course on the other hand
the university prepared citizens for
participating in society and is
therefore one of the most important and
efficient social agents it is also
perhaps a primary context for social
advancement as well as one of the
principal producers of invention and
innovation to transform the world we
inhabit these two roles and expectations
of the University have struggled with
one another continually hence it should
not come as a surprise that that when
current technology makes it possible for
us to freely share the product of our
work with not just our colleagues within
the university
with society at large we find elements
within and outside the university who
booked at the possibility or who view it
with suspicion my sense is though that
we're decidedly moving toward a totally
free and open availability of academic
production which is the reason why the
Graduate School has just as our peers
have as well embraced the open access
protocol and have begun to require that
students to posit the dissertations
electronically and to have that work
resided in a repository where they will
be accessible where it will be
accessible to all who wish to consult it
but I also believe that this
transformation within academia will in
fact pave the way for equally free and
open availability of all creative work
outside the Academy something that as
you may imagine will require a radically
new understanding of authorship property
rights copyright etc whose contours were
just beginning to see currently with
that I leave you with Kenneth cruise
director of Columbia's copyright
advisory office and the manager of
Columbia's academic commons robert
Hilliker thank
Thank You Dean Alonzo so I'm just want
to start with a quick introduction in
case folks are not familiar with
academic commons explaining a little bit
about what academic commons is as dean
alonso mentioned it's the digital
research repository it's for columbia
university but also for its affiliate
institutions so Barnard the Union
Theological Seminary Teachers College
and so on and what we do is we take the
digital scholarship that's produced here
at Columbia and its affiliates and we
archive that content so that will be
available in the future we follow best
practices for digital preservation and
we also follow best practices in terms
of things like search engine
optimization to make sure that that
content is available and accessible in
the present at the moment where we're
approaching 5,000 items in the
collection we really have a wide range
of content you know we started out with
mostly articles and working papers and
things of that more conventional
scholarly nature but we've been
branching out as scholarship itself has
been branching out into new media so now
we have presentation slides video data
sets and of course now we have the
dissertations starting this past
februari to date we have roughly 300
dissertations that have come in through
the GSS dissertation submission process
and obviously that's a large portion you
know of our growing content so we're
very proud and glad to have it there at
the at the current juncture we get
between six and eight thousand visitors
to our website each month so that's a
lot of people coming and looking at
columbia content and for the
dissertations you know in many cases
that means that they have a much wider
audience than they would otherwise have
had in the traditional print format you
know I did a PhD myself and you know I'm
sure it's sitting dusting on a shelf
somewhere and maybe one or two people
have looked at it but the dissertations
that are in the digital repository many
of them have been seen by hundreds of
people and downloaded in red and some of
them are you know cited in blogs or in
newspaper articles and it drives up you
know
interest in traffic their work their
scholarship is out there participating
in a larger universe a you know of
content and that's a wonderful thing so
quickly you know just to give you a
glimpse right this is the front page of
academic commons one one thing that I
really like about academic commons too
is that it's a multilingual place so
we're you know really aimed at providing
an internationally accessible you know
international access to the research and
scholarship that go on at Columbia so
you can see there you know some of our
recent content you can also get a
glimpse there we recently moved to a new
platform for our website and those
numbers there show the quarter before we
switched and the quarter after we switch
and you can see so rapidly increasing in
terms of the traffic that's coming to
our website which is you know a big plus
and we're always working to improve that
and to find new ways to you know
increase the the excitement around
academic commons and then bring in a new
audience but really why we're here today
is to talk about the submission the
electronic submission of theses and
dissertations so what does it mean to
submit electronically well the first
thing is that you know it cost less
because the processing is much simpler
you don't have to go out and buy some
fancy paper and worry about you know
printing properly and are my margins all
right in everything like that it also
means that you use the Umi ETD portal to
upload your dissertation and so there's
a lot of information on the GSS
dissertation submission gateway and if
you you know if you've got your smart
phones you can just scan that QR code
and go directly to the site but the web
address is also there and really you
know one thing I want to point out here
is is it's been a great thing for us at
academic commons to partner with Jesus
on this and so you know they are the
ones who have the information on their
website salvo candelas here he's someone
you can direct questions to about this
process but we are also here working in
partnership with them right to figure
out the issues that arise the
bumps that come along the road and on
that point you know I want to start
people thinking before they submit or
even when they're just starting to write
what are the implications of having your
work in academic commons because now
right even even with previously where
your dissertations were available
through you am I in a sense they were
published they were available publicly
somebody could go and buy a copy in PDF
or in print of your dissertation so they
were out there but they were not out
there in quite the same way they are now
when they can be accessed you know by
anybody on the web so a big piece of
that is yes you'll have a bigger
audience for your work and that's a
great thing another thing though is that
you need to think about what i'm calling
the three P's and also the sea and the
three P's our privacy about publication
and about Peyton law and so in terms of
privacy and I put there including your
own and this is an important point you
need to think when you're writing your
dissertation am I revealing anything
about the subjects of my research am I
revealing something about myself that I
wouldn't want out in the public domain
where anybody can see it and just to
give you a really extreme example that
came up out of the last batch of
dissertations that were submitted we had
a student who wrote her dissertation on
Zimbabwe and in the in the dissertation
she was critical in the Mugabe regime
and then she moved back to Zimbabwe and
so her dissertation was available for
anybody to find and so she had to you
know get in touch with us once she
realized because she you know hadn't
maybe paid attention to the mailings
that came out or what have you and so
didn't quite process that my
dissertation is going to be out there on
the web so she came to us and we very
quickly you know pulled her dissertation
down off the web made sure that any
cached copies from google or wherever
else were no longer available and very
quickly you know got it out of that
visible public space in order to try and
make sure that
you know there was no danger for her and
having it out there and so you know this
is an extreme case but I think it sort
of brings home that realization of hey
you know I need to think about what it
is that I'm putting out there the other
question is publication now it's in my
experience it's not very common for
people to turn around right after they
graduate and want to publish their
dissertation immediately but if you're
in a discipline where that is what you
do then it is possible to get a limited
term embargo for your dissertation
whether you're just making a chapter
available as an article or whether
you're turning around the entire
dissertation if it's the kind of thing
where you take longer the reality is
you're probably reworking your
dissertation radically it's not you know
the publishers are not going to see it
as the same thing as your dissertation
so they're not going to be bothered by
being out there but you do need to think
about this right because you need to
make that decision when you're
submitting do I want to have an embargo
do i want one year do I want to the
other piece related to that is patent
law and if you make your dissertation
available in academic commons or really
anywhere if you publish your work
there's a Peyton clock that starts
ticking once you publish that work of
how long you have to file for your
patent so you know you need to think
about that and if you don't have time
while you're writing your dissertation
to be doing that then you should be
looking to have an embargo so that you
can take that time to make sure that you
have you know your filing in place for
your for your Peyton and then the final
thing that you need to think about is
copyright law that's a whole different
talk Kenny's going to talk to you about
that but before I pass off to him I also
want to point out academic commons is
also available for your other scholarly
work not just your dissertations and
it's also there for materials that don't
fit in your dissertation right because
your dissertation is going to be a PDF
but if you have video if you have you no
image images or data sets that don't fit
in your dissertation that you want to
make available you can deposit them in
academic commons separately we will
register a permanent URL then that you
can cite in your dissertation and this
is something that you know came up last
year and we did
and full of of graduates for their
dissertations but I encourage you to
think about that and not just you know
not just things associated with your
dissertation but really any scholarly
work that you're doing if you're
publishing articles if you're making
presentations you can bring it to us
tomorrow we're going to be next door at
Butler in the digital humanities center
at three-thirty p.m. and we're having
what we call an academic commons deposit
party so if you bring your content on a
flash drive or if it's available on the
web you can come and we'll help you
deposit it in academic commons so that
that's tomorrow and then i also want to
point out that we're going to be this is
just the beginning in the spring Kenny
and I will be doing a series of
workshops to do more hands-on work so
that as you're writing and you come
across issues around copyright and
licensing you can bring them to us and
we'll help you work through them and
this is my contact information if if you
have any questions after the talk and
you you know don't want to have them in
front of the whole group you can always
email me as well thank you
thank you rob thanks to Dean thank you
to the organizers thanks to all of you
and by the way congratulations I think
that's an order because having many of
you or at the point where the completion
of the dissertation is in sight and we
certainly know that feeling don't waste
so it's a feeling that never leaves you
so you'll look forward to the day you
file and one of the things we want to
make sure happens and why we're here is
to make sure that that filing goes
easily and doesn't stir last minute
concerns and that you meet your deadline
so picking up where Rob left off I want
to talk a little bit about the copyright
implications of your dissertation and so
we should ask simple questions up front
like why are we paying attention to
copyright and there are really different
ways of answering that question one is
with a little bit of a legal spin and
that is that we can't avoid it it's
everywhere this is a problem of the
nature of the way copyright law is
structured so for example up on the
screen a list of a few different types
of works as examples of things that are
protected by copyright books and
periodicals literary works words have
all different in all different types of
works music video websites software and
your dissertation protected by copyright
let me let me digress as briefly as I
can into just one basic legal concept
and that is that copyright vests
automatically instantly and
automatically upon creation of these
works so you sit down and write your
dissertation as soon as you write a
sentence of paragraph not to mention the
entire dissertation where that piece is
your original work and it's fixed in
some tangible medium it is written on
paper it is saved
to the memory of your computer either
way it now qualifies for instant
automatic copyright protection so so are
you a copyright owner the answer is yes
have you even begun writing your
dissertation if you've gotten this far
into it you're probably a copyright
owner it's the way the law works which
means in turn that the materials were
find that we are finding and using are
also it's safe to presume almost always
protectable by copyright so let me ask
the same question and answer it in a
different way why are we paying
attention to copyright and let me give
you this approach to the question
because it's integral to your
scholarship and the success of your
scholarship that the better decisions
you make about copyright the more you're
going to affect the quality of your work
the accessibility of your work and the
impact of your work on the world of
researchers and scholars around you the
better you pay attention and address
copyright decision making the more you
have positioned yourself to take
advantage of any work that you produce
and its relationship for building upon
the next round of work that you are
doing the dissertation that becomes a
book the dissertation that becomes
research articles the research articles
have become successor research articles
the book that you're writing that you
want to build an accompanying website to
go with these all raised the importance
of considering and making good well
informed decisions about the management
of your copyrights in order to position
yourself to do those good things that we
just described so let me now look at
sort of the two coins the two sides of
the coin if you will of copyright there
are issues of ownership and as I've
already said you created the work you
own the work that's the basic assumption
of the way the law works and then we'll
be talking momentarily about your use of
other people's works so first the
ownership you will have decisions about
on what terms you want to claim and very
likely especially if you go through
ProQuest choose the option to register
the copyright in your work is that
necessary to register your work no but
it's fairly simple it's fairly cheap and
it gives you some benefits practical and
legal but upon recognizing that you are
the owner that means you have the right
to make some choices about your work to
post it to not post it to make it
available to not make it available to
choose whether you're going to say I own
the rights come see me or to release it
with a Creative Commons license that
openly permits others to use it albeit
under limited circumstances and then the
decision to make it publicly available
through ProQuest or publicly available
through academic commons and then
because it's your dissertation in the
future somebody may contact you and say
I would like permission to use it in
this way or that way and that becomes
your decision for how you want to allow
that to happen and I think is a very
important sub to that it's your decision
about how you are going to build
publications from your dissertation and
here to you want to think about the
terms on which you will sign agreements
with journal publishers book publishers
to advance your career with new works
that are based on your dissertation
research but a lot of what we want to
talk about today is the question of the
materials that you use in the
dissertation i'll be giving some
examples but think of it in these terms
that you write your dissertation the
pieces of it that are clearly yours that
you wrote that you created
those are yours we've already talked
about that but to the extent that you
are using somebody elses work and maybe
more specifically I should say to the
extent that you are including in your
dissertation somebody else's work from
the most ordinary quotation to the
extraordinary use of large numbers of
photos or software or music or other
pieces then we need to consider the
copyright implications of the use of
somebody else's work and so generally
our ability to use somebody else's work
from a copyright perspective means the
use fits into one of these categories up
on the screen right now that you've
determined that the work is in the
public domain and public domain in my
context means it is without legal
copyright protection and there are two
huge categories of public domain works
that arise often one is works for which
the copyright has expired now copyrights
last a long time we're talk is a lot of
complicated rules and we're generally
talking about early 20th century and
before somebody in the room is writing
on Chaucer Towser is predates the early
20th century last I checked he isn't
still around is he no so so a lot of
those works are in the public domain if
you're writing about World War one
you're in the realm of working with
things that are in the public domain if
you're writing about World War two now
you're in the realm of things that are
likely protected by copyright but a lot
of stuff is public domain another broad
category of public domain works works
produced by the United States government
not the county government not the state
government the United States government
so that report from the State Department
that report from the National Park
Service those are good works that very
often are in beam to be in the public
domain so another big category
and one that could be an extensive
subject of an extensive discussion we'll
see how we get to it is fair use and the
appropriate fair use of of works another
important category is permissions we
contacted the copyright owner requested
permission got the permission we need we
included it or creative commons i
mentioned creative commons a few minutes
ago in terms of making the work your
work available you're choosing to put a
Creative Commons license on the work but
you know a lot of other people have
chosen to put Creative Commons licenses
on their works and when you find that if
it's krivit the Creative Commons license
is broad enough then follow the rules
typically give attribution
non-commercial use that kind of thing
then you're okay or other pre licensed
sources and there are many of them out
there and by the way those of you
looking for photographs for example to
include in your dissertation there are
multitudes of different online resources
for photographs and many of well-known
ones such as flickr have creative
commons licenses attached to them so you
go in there you dip in you find the
photo you want there it says creative
commons attribution you give your
attribution in the dissertation and
you've probably done what's required to
be able to properly use that work so
some examples think about your own
dissertation what do you have in it so
you might have maps and other kinds of
graphic works you might have music could
be sheet music it could be recorded
music you might have artworks
two-dimensional paintings
three-dimensional sculptural works all
of which may very well be protectable by
copyright you may have literary works as
you quote from some other source the
standard quotation is the use of
somebody else's work and it may be
copyright protected so we have a number
of different ways
that we can include copyrighted works in
their dissertation but reminding you
about this list the the your your
concern and maybe concern is even
overstating it but you're thinking
should be with each of those works if I
have any of these in my dissertation
have I worked through thinking is that
item in the public domain is more is my
use fair use or do I have permission or
do they get it from a Creative Commons
or other licensed source and so that's
the approach that you'll need to take to
your dissertation so keeping it in
perspective plan ahead many of these
tasks honestly do not take much time but
often the most time-consuming aspect is
if for example I need to secure
permission it might take a little while
to get permission i'm working on a
permission request for one of my own
projects right now and and and i'm
probably going to get that request back
in a matter of hours or days once I
polish it and send send off and identify
exactly what I'm requesting but in other
cases it may take weeks or months
because somebody may not be there to
answer their slow or their bogged down
and you need to send a reminder and then
another reminder and so plan ahead and
begin the process early be reasonable be
reasonable this is this is this is this
is not highly complex detailed work
probably nobody is going to die because
of the copyright issues so be reasonable
about how much pressure you're putting
on yourself and how you're going to be
able to advance addressing these
concerns keep all of your options open
and and by that I mean back on that
previous slide where it could be
permission it could be fair use it could
be public domain you're going to have
different answers for different types of
works this one is this
next one is something else the next work
is something else so keep all of your
options open consider your alternatives
and not only legal alternatives but
consider alternatives for the works that
you are using I've had many many
instances where somebody comes to me and
says I'm running into problems clearing
whatever rights I need to use this map
and very often my responses do you
really need that map or could another
one serve your purposes as well and
usually the responses oh I don't know I
never thought of that I saw that map
admit my needs I didn't get past
thinking about it so do think past the
particular immediate desires that you
have to explore your alternatives and as
you track owners send off letters of
request determine whether something is
fair use get it from a creative common
source whatever your situation might be
keep careful notes about what you found
where you found it when you made those
phone calls keep copies of the emails
you sent to somebody and keep all of
that material keep all of that material
really indefinitely you never know when
the question is going to come up and
then by planning ahead and planning
carefully most important point graduate
on time get going if you're thinking
you're going to be for example aim a
graduate of next year you should begin
this process immediately so that maybe
you'll be done with it by December so
you don't have to worry about it come
May and that would be an excellent thing
for you to do and then beyond that for
substance let me refer you to the
copyright advisory office website where
you'll find a rich variety of materials
I hope you'll find them helpful I
welcome your feedback and comments about
them but you'll find a quick guide to
walk you through in about a page and a
half the principles and functioning of
copyright you'll find a variety of
materials about ownership including how
to manage you
work and publication agreements a lot of
material about fair use as well as about
permissions some guidance about what's
in the public domain and some links out
to those resources where you can find
photographs and other images many of
which are with Creative Commons licenses
so I thank you very much and I think we
look forward to any questions you might
have about anything thank you so for
those whose work deals mainly with art
or cultural objects where many photos
may not exist that are obviously usable
without having to contact someone for
permission what would maybe qualifies a
fair use of that image is it just
because it's for an academic reason is
there a size restriction anything else
about fair use that you might fall for
yeah really really good question really
good question and and so and I think you
could ask your your your bottom line
question we could ask about a variety of
contexts so just in really broad terms
you found an image presumably somebody
else owns the copyright to that image is
it fair use for me to include it in a
dissertation what you'll find when you
go to the website and begin reading
about fair use is that the answer to any
fair use question depends upon a reason
balanced application of four factors
that are in the statute but let me give
you a concrete example if we go back to
this this image you can almost tell
what's going on in the picture down here
in the bottom corner that that's
actually a photograph that I took from a
book about the history of the Grateful
n anybody riding their dissertation on
the Grateful Dead no all right did wrong
generation the the end and it happened
that I have this book in my collection
not because I'm a Deadhead but because
it was a copyright case if you can see
right here in the center of that page
that's actually a little small
reproduction of one of those great rock
and roll posters from the 60s and 70s
psychedelic etc and here came the
lawsuit from the copyright owner of that
poster against the publisher of the book
saying that violated my copyright in
your reproduction of it and the court
ruled that that was fair use so let me
go through those four factors the first
factor is what's the purpose of your use
and even though this is a commercial
product it also had the purpose of being
an educational work meant to inform
readers about the history of music and
the Grateful Dead in particular and so
on and so that tended to be mixed
purposes but that lean generally in
favor of informing the readers like your
dissertation the nature of the work
highly artistic which tends to weigh
against fair use but also emblematic of
the times so it's a historical artifact
here's a key point amount when the court
analyzed the third factor which is
what's the amount of the work that
you're using they said yeah it's the
whole thing it's the whole poster but
it's small size it's low resolution and
it's in a context of discussion and
analysis rather than like a tear out of
the whole thing where you could
reproduce the poster in full and then
the effect on the market yes that
posters available for sale but the court
said using a small low res image doesn't
interfere with the market so think about
your putting a photograph in your
tation you can learn from examples like
this go back to fair use and you could
say yeah my purpose is purely
educational academic analytical that
weighs in favor of fair use the nature
of the work that's going to vary from
example example but amount there's a I
think there's a big difference between
small low res versus large-scale plate
high-res full-color kind of thing if
it's also small low res wrapped in text
that's going to help you a lot and then
the effect on the market depends upon is
this work being marketed is it being
marketed specifically and realistically
for your kind of use as opposed to sales
of a poster so I think you're going to
find you know I've seen many of these
where somebody's doing in art history
thesis dissertation and if you're
telling me the page is this big but my
image is this big and it's small black
and white low res wrapped in text so
it's clearly analytical honestly in most
situations like that I'm going to feel
pretty comfortable about fair use and I
suspect you are too if it's full color
at the back where you can tear it out
then maybe I'm not going to be so
comfortable does that help yeah good
just wanted to ask for clarification and
a couple of points that you made I'm in
the second presentation you said that
there are a couple of decisions that we
had to make and one of the decisions was
whether or not we wanted to make it
available to the commons academic
commons and I my impression from from
the Dean is that that's not an option
though that's the requirement right so
then you want to talk about yeah
probably know a related question
assuming that it is a requirement yeah
then the second presentation you also
said that we have the option that we
both the audit copyright was both
automatic and then we also have the
option of requesting filing for official
copyright and I don't understand what
the distinction is there and then lastly
if it is required then I from the first
presentation I don't understand exactly
what an embargo is and and why would you
choose that okay so I'll take questions
one and three has two of two getting
ofuro answer those so the first question
is what is the GSS policy the GSS policy
is that your dissertation will be
deposited in academic commons and so the
option that is available that we call an
embargo basically means there's a
limited term in which we will hold your
dissertation separate from the publicly
accessible academic commons so that you
know you elect when you file a period of
one year or two years to have your
dissertation not available in academic
commons and you know then during that
time if you need to you know consider
peyton or you know other considerations
that allows you to do that
that's it your discretion at the time of
final okay okay yeah good thing thank
you thank you for that and then and then
on your your second question was one
about automatic copyright protection vs
I didn't say this but copyright notice
as well as registration of the work the
way the law works is as soon as you
create that new work you get instant
automatic protection so in almost every
case it would be a very odd unusual case
that this wasn't true I could look at
every one of you and say you're all
writing a dissertation I can tell you
even before I see your dissertation and
know who you are and willing to bet that
it it is going to be protected by
copyright because you just can't avoid
it's the way the law works but then you
can gain additional legal rights by
putting a copyright notice see in a
circle copyright by me 2011 there are
some legal rights that go with that you
can gain some additional legal rights if
you register the work with the US
Copyright Office but do you have to do
either those no not at all not at all
but you know they're easy they're not
expensive they do give you some benefits
if you need them so you might as well
you just might as well and then if
nothing else it creates the public
record that here's my dissertation I
know about copyright here's an address
where you can reach me that goes on the
registration form and that's helpful to
users to be able to track you down as
well so that's a good thing
as giasses policy towards
so that that's something that's
essentially required by GS yes
and end as does the Jesus policy permit
you to add more information so in other
words on that page too could I say
copyright 2011 by me and then say I
hereby grant permission to anybody to
make copies of this yes could I do that
we do love that may be allowed students
to place specifically please that was
gonna be the next question so yeah yeah
Creative Commons is a way of saying I
own the copyright but I hereby permit
the world to use it in this manner as an
art historian with a potentially very
large PDF file dissertation with lots of
images I've a couple of questions first
officer a maximum limit to file size to
posting to the academic commons and
second off is it possible to submit a
lower resolution maybe black and white
images less reproducible to the academic
comments to obtain fair use for some of
these images but then reserved higher
resolution full color version for more
limited distribution sure so I'll take
your apartment yep
rights to is there any way of doing kind
of odd walk witchblade to the high um so
whichever version you submit to ProQuest
is the version that comes through to
academic commons so whatever they've
done with the file will be that they
make available will be the file that we
end up receiving but I would taking your
questions backwards then say that you
know it's entirely possible to have the
dissertation that's reviewed by your
committee and then have the version
that's submitted and they shouldn't you
know if there if there are those
unresolved licensing or permissions
issues that's one way to address that is
too
okay um but in terms of the file size
you know I think the largest
dissertation we have is probably over a
gigabyte so you know and up to two
gigabytes we can handle it you know
relatively straightforward if it
happened to clear two gigabytes you know
we can talk and we can probably figure
it out but you know we've we've handled
you know files up to a gigabyte and a
half and you know you know i'll just say
too I like the way you thought through
your alternatives I mean if it's okay
with you and if it's okay with your
committee I see it is a very okay thing
for you to do to say in the dissertation
form my images may not be perfect i'll
look like this and that gets the job
done and it avoids all kinds of other
headaches and then i'll just save the
worrying about permissions and fees and
clearances for when i land a publication
contract with a journal with a book
publisher whatever and we'll work it out
with the publisher then on the more time
consuming and maybe more expensive
processes I mean another thing I would
add is because you're submitting is a
PDF you know you can also have the URLs
to resources that if they're on the web
but you haven't cleared the permissions
you can still provide access through
your dissertation that you're submitting
I
just brought up this morning I just
signed away the copyright privileges to
get one of my chapters published in a
journal so I'm going to use that chapter
as a district as a I'm gonna use that
paper that as part of a chapter in my
dissertation and I imagine about half my
dissertation will probably I won't have
the copyrights for but maybe because I'm
in the sciences so as the papers come
out you just kind of send them up to the
journals so how does that work with some
of the chapters like maybe half your
dissertation so I mean it depends
partially on the publishers because they
all have different policies but I mean
as a baseline you know the thing is that
when you're submitting you are offering
that you've cleared the permissions for
your work to be available and that's not
just record in the commons that's also
pro quests requirement that when you
submit to them that you be you know
submitting something to them that they
can make available but so with the
scientific publishers in many cases
their policies basically what they're
saying is yeah they take over the
copyright but they let you you know give
you back a certain range of licenses
license your backs are a number of
rights among which generally is the
ability to make you know what I mean the
fact is the chapter is not going to be
the article right it's not going to be
formatted it's not going to be you know
just a PDF earring from their website I
think it would be best the planet well
okay and if if if depending on their
policy that may be okay that may not be
okay you may need to use the version
you've submitted to them rather than the
version after it was reviewed yeah you
know or you maybe need to use the
version that was reviewed but not the
final version that got published so
there's a resource called
Romeo and you know if you want you can
get in touch with us we can help you use
that or point you to that but that
allows you to check the policies of
different journals and different
publishers about the reuse of material
where you've signed over the copyright
and and and and my first question for
you is is this already gone out in the
mail um it's all electronics it's all
electronic yet that's each other's yeah
well the thing is that if you want is to
keep the copyrights you had to pay a
very large fee oh yeah don't do um which
yeah don't do that right that's what my
advice that it's a subject of another
discussion which we've covered well and
you can find videos up on in the cedar
space on YouTube and so on where we've
talked about some of these issues before
but it is immediately obviously your
case makes the point that this is
immediately important in the writing of
the dissertation but carry this lesson
over throughout your career as you're
signing that publication agreement ask
yourself a very practical question what
do I want to do with this content in the
future and make a list it's not legal
stuff this is just practical I want to
include it in my dissertation I want to
hand out copies to my students I want to
write new research that builds on this
and maybe borrow some paragraphs I want
to write a book and this could become a
chapter in a book make a list of what
youth one is a practical matter and ask
for those things from your publisher so
staple and addendum to the agreement
that says this is an addendum to
agreement I reserve the right to do a B
and C whatever they'll let you have and
this is very this is true this will be
true for your entire career be very
watchful of the documents you sign and
then if nothing else guess what I'm
going to say next keep a copy did you
keep a copy of the document you shipped
off to them oh it is
electronic yeah I agree the printed he
did you hit the print key did you save
it I saved in my inbox yeah okay good
save it and save it forever copyrights
last for the life of the author so
however long you live plus 70 more years
we need that document for at least that
many years in order to know the pedigree
of this copyright so hang on to those
documents forever you get a permanent
file of your publication agreements so I
mean I know it's this is commonly done
in the sciences where someone will
submit a chapter you know paper I'll get
published and that'll be part of their
dissertation so I could still have my
dissertation available to in the
academic commons right in the commons
even I mean in the reality is you know
the lawyer in me can't say you're home
free because you're not so there but the
reality is nobody's going to give you a
hard time about this except one party
ProQuest ProQuest they will do a cursory
review of your dissertation and if they
see those PDF pages they're going to
contact you and say can we can we see
your permission letter for washing up
it'll be a problem yeah getting that
yeah so that's that that may be where
you are as long as you have it you're
fine as long as as long as you have the
permission letters from the journal yeah
if you have the permission letter then
you're in great shape you're great shape
and that could be a simple email it
doesn't take much magic you really don't
yeah yeah one reprinting of that nature
is fairly common yeah but but you do
need to go through that stuff about
asking for it yeah my point is I think
you're fine is just watch for these
things in your routine practice in the
future thanks good
those things that's right
like a bed zero thank you put in your
information and just auto creates PDF
for the sample so you don't have to
worry about you know copy pasting
thank you
the embargo or the academic comments
would that allow me to sort out
copyright issues or I have to be done
with all that when I actually foul the
dissertation I would say that it's
better to sort them out before you
submit and for the reason that it's not
just academic commons it's also ProQuest
and so you can get embargoes with both
but you know the fact is if you if you
submit a particular version and then
were you know we're just waiting that
one year or two years at which point
we'll make it available the version that
we got and so if you in that time
weren't able to clear up all the
copyright issues that would leave us in
a gray area where you would have
submitted your dissertation write the
version of record and then that version
can't be made available because there's
a copyright problem so I would say
before you submit resolve what you can
and you know if you need to redact
things or you know have low resolution
images or however you manage that you
know submit that version just
from GSA SS point of view with your
dissertation this requirement for the
PhD degree it's important to us that the
copy of the dissertation that you
deposit is the final version of
dissertation because once you deposit
that we give you your degree and so it
can wait until after that point to
resolve copyright issues and it turns
out that whatever reason you change the
content of your dissertation that's a
problem because now there's a new
version of your dissertation post
actually floated around 20 degrees so
from an academic point of view as far as
academic policy of GS it's important
that if your dissertation is on the
state
use dissertations that have actually not
is
and
do I by purchasing that step 2
directions where I mean they're from
if i'm understanding does the fact these
are images that you purchased from a
supplier a gallery a museum and and the
the answer to the question I've I've
studied a lot of these museum licenses
and practices and and they very often
are selling an image from a museum that
comes with a long list of conditions you
know very often it's dense pack detail
of these are the terms on which you may
now use this image read it very
carefully make sure it covers what you
what you want and because it's
conceivable that they will even say you
cannot do this this and this and that's
exactly what you wanted so so read those
very carefully make sure before you
spend money acquiring those images that
in fact it's going to come with the
permission that you need because if it
doesn't then you're back at best you're
back to considering fair use which may
mean you spent a lot of money to get a
high resolution image and now you're
only going to use it as a small a small
low res version which you might as well
scan out of a textbook if that's the
case so
to me there's no
your way you're you're kind of not
necessarily I mean these are archival
materials yeah and I'm trying my best to
sort of repeat the question into the
answer for capturing it on tape but
you're kind of back at the beginning
which is an okay place to be really
where you have that list of alternatives
I mean if this is an image of an
archival manuscript from 1725 well then
odds are overwhelming this is a public
domain work anyway you don't need
anybody's permission and so so you may
just go ahead and quote from it maybe
even reprint the manuscript into your
work you have to size up the situation
one at a time and then the book is from
what year 1875 odds are overwhelming
that that work is in the public domain
published book yeah published in the
United States maybe even that gets a
little iffy but odds are small that
there's going to change anything if you
go to the you know what is the public
domain and duration of copyright
material there's a basic rule you
remember my world war one world war two
anecdote that if it's published before
1923 published in the united states and
foreign publications are mostly the same
if it's published before 1923 it's
public domain may be your only concern
is does the archive think that it has
some rights somehow in this image but
that does it doesn't affect the text the
text itself is public domain so if
you're just quoting go to your heart's
content
probably we'd have to look at it I'm not
here to say yes or no without seeing the
specifics but probably yeah good any
other questions well we thank you very
much thank you pleasure best wishes to
all of you